we kind of have to vote because we're
gonna have to live here and especially
cuz we're 268 this our boat actually
matters
I was really really disappointed when I
was told I couldn't vote because I've
been looking forward to it for pretty
much my entire life and I've done the
research night knew what was gonna
happen and then that was a curveball
that I wasn't expecting they were really
engaged student they wanted to vote the
primary they were really involved they
were really sitting find it they wanted
to vindicate their writing myself and my
group of friends really care about
social justice issues like racial issues
and gender issues and LGBT issues these
issues determine whether these people
live or die with their quality of life
for their living in poverty whether they
can afford to feed their families and
class of 2017 we all care a lot about
this because it's going to affect our
lives as new adults and how we perceive
the world once we are not children
anymore
you